these standing stones are enormous and
made of solid granite when you near them
they are genuinely impressive and
imposing the sort of thing that makes
you wonder how ancient people ever
managed to raise them up and to place
them so precisely that they act as an
astronomical calendar these particular
stones don't make you wonder that though
because these are the Georgia
Guidestones in the USA and they were put
up in 1980 by modern people with modern
equipment they are not a theme-park
fiberglass replica though they are more
than a hundred tons of rock and they are
built to last
inscribed on them in eight languages are
what seem to me rules for a future
post-apocalyptic civilization the sort
of thing that maybe seemed like a
reasonable way to send a message to the
far distant future in an era when the
Cold War was looking dicey and Ronald
Reagan's finger was very close to the
nuclear button the person or people who
paid for these stones stayed anonymous
so no one knows if they were actually
intending to troll conspiracy theorists
maybe they really were just hoping to
create a modern Stonehenge something
that could be taken as a set of
principles for the world's population to
follow as we recovered after an
apocalypse this might seem like a
reasonable purchase even altruistic from
a certain perspective if you're the sort
of person who writes a story in your
head that says yes I'll be dead in a
nuclear fireball but if civilization
survives perhaps someone will will come
across these perhaps some language will
have survived perhaps I I will have
influenced the entire path of a
civilization to come I mean it would
take a lot of money and a lot of ego but
then it was America in the 1980s so
perhaps we should just be surprised that
there aren't more stones like this all
over the place imagine it a dozen
different monuments all with different
rules and all being followed by a
different group of survivors
I don't normally speculate like listen
videos but these stones inspire some
pretty good stories and some pretty bad
ones too because like I said if you want
to inflame conspiracy theorists building
a modern Stonehenge that acts as an
astronomical calendar with Ten
Commandments inscribed upon it one of
which says that you should guide
reproduction wisely and another that
says it be a
really good idea to have a world
population under 10% of what it
currently is and doing all that while
hiding your identity yeah I can see why
they might make people with a slightly
tenuous grasp on reality a bit angry all
the best secret societies after all do
put up a giant monuments advertising
their goals for the world maybe someday
we will know the real reasons behind
these stones but until then there is a
rule of thumb called Occam's razor the
simplest solution tends to be the
correct one and a rich person who saw
Stonehenge and thought I want one of
those is a pretty simple solution
[Music]
[Applause]